und auch an diesem dienstag ist krieg
seit fast einem halben jahr inzwischen
kriegsalltag und der sieht so aus sie
plündern sie vergewaltigen sie foltern
und sie sind auch noch stolz darauf in
grausamen bildern zeigen russische
truppen märz wie sie ukrainische
kriegsgefangene missbrauchen bevor sie
sie dann kaltblütig ermorden in diesem
internierungslager verbrennt russland 53
kriegsgefangene ein russischer soldat
schneidet einem ukrainer hier in dieser
brutalen szene die hoden ab danach
erschießt er in putins barbaren armee
sie filmt ihre eigenen kriegsverbrechen
prahlt mit vergewaltigung bei kollegen
und bei familie und der ukrainische
präsident der schwört sein land auf
vergeltung 1 gegen den wie er sagt
terrorstaat russland
ich hole mir ein foto pro jahr heute
möchte ich allen einwohnern von nico
lange für ihre unbeugsamkeit danken
dafür dass sie die stadt und die region
geschützt haben ich danke auch nicoles
charkiw ribery und der gesamten region
mehr profit offs den starken menschen
von sabrina und der region allen ukraine
der region char soll allen die die
außenbezirke von odessa und der region
verteidigen ich danke ihnen für ihren
mut strategisch gesehen hat russland
keine chance diesen krieg zu gewinnen
und es ist notwendig durch zu halten
damit der terrorstaat auch auf
taktischer ebene seine niederlage spüren
wir müssen im süden osten und überall
durchhalten wir müssen in der
verteidigung der diplomatie und der
politik durchhalten wir müssen unsere
einheit bewahren und zwar nicht nur bis
zum sieg sondern auch danach um alles
was die besatzer zerstört haben
qualitativ wieder herzustellen ich
glaube dass wir dies alles schaffen
werden
[Musik]